Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google Developer's
Live.
My name's Ali, and today I'm
going to be talking to you
about Google Drive and the new
photo experience with Google+.
So we've launched just recently
one of my favorite
absolute features.
And it's something
I use a lot.
Why?
Because I store my photos
in Google Drive.
I find it very, very
convenient.
I take my camera.
I have a couple of cameras.
I plug the SD card into my
computer, and I just upload
them to Drive.
Now, one of the really important
things about Google
Drive and what I keep going on
about, if you've ever heard me
say anything, I'm always
going on about this.
So sorry about the
broken record.
But files don't go into to
Google Drive to die.
Google Drive is a place where
files go to live and be happy.
You use them with other
applications, with third party
applications.
We're always talking about
third party applications.
And example for a photo might
be PicMonkey, something to
touch up the photo or
put a background,
various editing features.
Now, one example of this
application is Google+, and
not just because Google+ is--
a Google product doesn't mean it
shouldn't be subject to the
same things.
So we launched this
integration.
And it allows you to treat
photos that are in your Google
Drive as if they were
in Google+.
So we'll have a look
at a computer.
I set up-- this is our test
account, and I had a fun
morning this morning setting it
up to use Google+, but as
you can see, I've got
a few photos here.
I've uploaded them.
And as I logged in this morning
to my Google+ account,
it asked me, do you want
to use photos that
are in Google Drive?
So it gave me this prompt to
explain what it was doing and
that's for you to see
how it works.
And it asked me and
I said yes.
And since then, and this was
quite recently, started to--
I go to Google+.
If I look at my photos,
it started to
upload these into Google+.
You only see a couple of have
come in at the moment, but if
you see in Google+ in my photos,
you see that this icon
that says--
it's the Drive icon, so
I know that this is a
file in Google Drive.
So that's really exciting.
Why is it exciting?
Well, before we had to--
if we wanted to insert a photo
into Google+, you could
actually insert then
from Google Drive.
So I'd go in here, and you see
these are the ones that
haven't yet been indexed.
I would go in here, and I would
look at them, and I
would choose one.
But now, if you see this photo
and this one and the ones that
are being indexed slowly.
I can actually insert
them directly.
So let's do one just so
you know this is a
live show, why not?
Hi, Google Drive developers.
Hi everyone from GDL.
So let's see, where do we
want to share it to?
Google Drive developers.
Let's see, there's a shameless
plug, why not?
So now, I'm sharing this and
it's directly from Google
Drive, so it's treating my
Google Drive photos as if
they're in Google+.
So my message here is remember,
files going to
Google Drive is a place where
you can then use them.
You can share them with people
privately inside Google Drive,
if you want to.
They can collaborate on them or
you can share them publicly
now in Google+.
So that's the first message.
The second message here is
that when I look at these
files, the whole goal here is to
unify the experience across
Google products.
Now, I'll be the first to
admit that we haven't
done a great job.
We have photos here.
We have photos there.
But this is gradually a step
towards unifying the entire
experience.
And obviously, we realized that
having one place to store
photos is better than having a
few places to store photos, as
long as it has the rich features
and the ability for
people to do what
they want to do.
So we think this integration is
a good step towards that.
We've still got a lot
of work to go.
I just want to show you that
really this is a high
priority for us.
The user experience here is
really, really important.
And we want you to get the
best out of your files.
This is your media.
This is your content.
This is stuff you created.
So from a developer point of
view, remember, Drive makes
files live, and we're trying
to unify the experience.
And this is a step in
that direction.
So thanks very much
for joining me.
If you have any questions,
follow up on the community,
email me personally.
I'm happy to talk to you.
So take care, everyone.
Bye, bye.